I'm born and raised in Brooklyn so I
could tell you're not from here but you
fit in well
Oh think I'm telling you do you like
when you order a coffee just order the
coffee you don't talk about the
integrity of the bean I'm like give me
that yeah straight up yeah your food
would right Ridgewood Bushwick
borderline yeah why are you so shady
it's not about shady it's when I mean
you're Bloomberg was the mayor change
the borderlines
while I was born in Brooklyn made it
Queens so now I've identity crisis know
what it feels like when the border
crosses you eggs there see what's up
everybody welcome to stupid questions
with Krista Stefano I'm here with my boy
Arturo Castro who's got a new show
coming out on Comedy Central called
alternate Eno rolls off the time I like
it
what would you rather go without sex or
alcohol alcohol alcohol you're good yeah
yeah drink no booze I'm just like a
social drinker man Rio and just like
social every day before noon you need to
have sex
not even I just need to procreate at
some point you know absolutely dude I
got a daughter well you know what my
daughters are latina Oh what about that
watch alternate II know she's Puerto
Rican yeah yeah Marlon all right so is
that that what's different I'm kidding
it happens that everybody in a party
that's ever been to fourroux once in
their life yeah brah yeah I've been to
Peru yeah how was it next to the
question yeah if you were ever to get
arrested god forbid a bit what would
your family assume your crime was
probably with yeah are you scared of
clowns dude yeah freak me out dude they
freak me out admire all people in the
clown industry yeah I'm just saying I
had a clown seven years old he smelled
like booze could he speedily payaso okay
what is that a dish if I have payaso
means clown Crispino pie lasso to me
just sounds delicious
Christina Palacio it sounds like a girl
like I would go on a date with and then
her father BIC if you talk to my
daughter I seen the Pilate over there I
was the kind of guy like he would just
walk on the treadmill with sunglasses on
here's an idea would you rather be a guy
who's known to drink his own pee or go
on romantic dates with his relatives
would you rather been drinking my own
pee now well actually don't truth be
told you drink in my opinion and what
cousin do you think it's okay I'll marry
them and just the old loud sound the
risk I think once you get to the second
cousin you're good to go
what if your first cousins a smoke show
no I rather the drink my own pee yeah
yeah you know what I like about you have
been talking for a little while you walk
past from the street back I hate that
guy because of his hat but now I like
you a lot
you got a lot of times the people called
me shitty Bruno Mars on the street hi
here's a question okay would you rather
for it every time you laughed or would
you rather go ahead every time somebody
said something depressing
I don't mind party or whatever probably
every time I laugh now after I get old
it's like I can't keep anything in a
family perfume is so it smells real nice
yeah but farting in your house was
dangerous if your mom at all those
chemicals going up you couldn't the
whole thing go up in flames
yeah because that's how it works yo cuz
I know you know no spark listen I don't
know how to do I'm not good with gas I
do electric hard you have a good time on
stupid questions awesome time bro dude I
want to get you a gift okay so the first
thing I got you cuz you're Latino yeah
so I got you soccer ball
Oh what it says England on it well
because that's stupid but I just thought
you know England's aw it's a nice
country thank you so much and then also
because you are narcos and you're from
you know I just got your kilo of that's
actually pure cocaine so look I'm
Maradona I'm Krista Stefano this has
been our toured all cast it all and
we've had a good time and you're gonna
watch when it comes out pretty soon
alterna no yo soy christopher then cool
yo soy you have to do Castro
you